journal de la rédaction nous sommes le
vendredi 24 octobre et il sera question
aujourd'hui de l' enquête sur la mort de
la science vital associations militant
contre l'avortement et l'euthanasie
vient de présenter les résultats de sa
propre enquête sur les rapports des
français à la mort objectif défendre la
vie le passage à l'heure d'hiver ce sera
dans la nuit de samedi à dimanche une
association se bat pour sa suppression
sa présidente eléonore gabarain est en
plateau pour nous expliquer pourquoi
elle considère que cette modification de
rythme et néfaste pour la santé et
n'apportent aucune économique la
secrétaire d'état en charge de la
politique de la ville attrape la cpm qui
l'ont sa campagne de vaccination contre
la grippe dans les yvelines
nous reviendrons aussi comme chaque fin
de semaine sur l'essentiel de
l'actualité depuis lundi engagé contre
le mariage pour tous l'alliance vita
fondée par christine boutin se réclament
surtout comme une association pro vie et
se bat contre l'avortement et
l'euthanasie pour appuyer sa démarche
ses adhérents ont mené depuis mars
dernier une enquête sur le rapport des
français à la mort baptisé parlons la
mort le bilan de cette enquête a été
présenté ce vendredi matin à versailles
al'approche du noeud novembre jour de la
fête des disparus une exposition avec
des photos des personnes témoignant sont
d'ailleurs présentés au gymnase richard
mique jusqu'au pendant trois semaines
par la mort est de moins en moins
familière de moins en moins de gens
meurent chez eux
on voit de moins en moins de gens mourir
et du cou et bien cette mort est de plus
en plus occulter ya comme une
conspiration du silence en fait autour
de cette mort et nous a semblé important
de libérer la parole autour de ce sujet
donc nous sommes allés dans la rue
avec
pour rencontrer des personnes et pour
recueillir leurs témoignages personnels
sur leur expérience de la fin de vie et
au terme de ce de ce témoignage
on les invités à écrire en une phrase ce
que l'accompagnement d'une personne en
fin de vie leur avait apportés pour leur
vie la jirs est la conclusion la plus
synthétique c'est que parler de la mort
fait du bien voilà fait du bien pour la
vie et libère des forces de vie font le
travail de deuil n'a pas été fait les
gens sont dans une vraie souffrance et
c'est effectivement ça peut être
libérateur il n'est plus belles phrases
cm à la mort fait partie de la vie c'est
un peu la conclusion de notre opération
je reçois pour ce dernier journal de la
semaine et l'honneur gaba un bonjour et
bienvenue vous êtes la présidente de
l'association contre l'heure d'été
double ce week-end nous allons à passer
à l'heure d'hiver dimanche à 3 heures du
matin il sera en fait deux heures cela
ne vous plaît pas particulièrement
plaisir vous allez nous dire pourquoi
mais tout d'abord un micro-trottoir
faut-il supprimer cette heure d'hiver
cette heure d'été voici vos réponses
dans les rues de saint quentin en
yvelines pas d'accord parce qu'on n'est
pas aligné au soleil du coup c'est pas
naturel de d'avoir un d un décalage
pareil oui pourquoi
pourquoi parce que je trouve que ça a
une influence négative sur le
comportement humain je trouve pas que
les économies d'énergie sont au
rendez-vous à escompter je vois pas trop
la différence parce que pour les enfants
ça dérègle un peu d habitude était
automne hiver et que sa tante à grand
chose pour moi je supprimerai pour qu'on
n'ait pas la nuit qui tombe trop tôt
l'hiver je supprimerai tout à fait en
plus au niveau des enfants c'est
compliqué c'est compliqué une vis-à-vis
de leur rythme sur un peu quoi donc moi
ça vaut vraiment pas encore vraiment
aucun intérêt c'est l'unanimité il faut
supprimer ce changement d'heure vous
êtes plutôt satisfaite de voir j'imagine
que votre avis est largement partagé
mais expliquez nous pourquoi tout
simplement vous militez depuis presque
une trentaine d'années contre 7h10 vers
7 heures d'été oui en fait c'est si nous
avons conscience et nous le disons
toujours que la france avance et deux
heures en période en période d'été ce
qui est un cas très rare dans le monde
et est d'ailleurs on se demande pourquoi
puisque bon avant nous avancions une
heure depuis que le général de gaulle a
instauré une avancée permanente des
l'heure légale rapport à l'heure du
fuseau et ça suffisait pour faire
plaisir à certains
et ça posait pas de problème donc
excessive mais avec l'heure d'été double
on cumule la complication pour le
transport du changement avec une retard
de l'obscurité qui nuit au sommeil et de
la fatigue et aussi des conditions moins
bonnes pour le travail donc en fait ce à
un coût économique alors pas des
économies ça coûte plus cher pour la
santé bien sûr que ça coûte plus cher
savait que les problèmes d'insomnie sont
la première cause de consultation en
france que nous sommes les champions du
monde de la consommation de somnifères
et en fait côté énergie de plus en plus
de spécialistes contact il ya plutôt une
perte et pour les loisirs même si
certaines personnes en profitent
un jour ouvrable donc pour l'ensemble de
la population en week end ou en vacances
donc c'est moins bon partout quoi parce
que d'abord il faut récupérer le sommeil
et puis beaucoup d'équipements fait
quand même très tôt par rapport à la
hauteur naturel il faut se dépêcher
on va changer
on va reculer d'une heure mais on aura
toujours une heure d'avancé par rapport
à la normalité en fait un hiver oui je
vous demander c'est quoi c'est qu'on
supprime l'heure d'été et leurs divers
qu'on s'aligne sur quelle horreur vous
voilà donc qu entend rester comme vous
dites comme avait voulu général de
gaulle donc avait juste une heure
d'avancé toute l'année il yad'autres les
associations qui veut qui qui qui
suggère qu ont adopté leur diffusion on
est heureusement ça serait peut-être les
mieux mais déjà une heure d'enfance sans
changement sait on l'a vécu et séné ça
pose pas peur vous savez souvent il ya
quand même des horaires moins matinaux
quand on avancer d'une heure bien vécu
en espagne on avance en fait plus d'une
heure et les écoliers commencent à 9h
par 80 1 donc quand on sait que les
allemands commencent plus tôt
mais avec avec les deux heures d'avancé
en été figurez vous que les écoliers
commencent à 6h30 preuve du fiso que les
familles se lève à 4h30 et donc il s'est
passé pas étonné qu'ils aiment problème
d'arrivée scolaire qui ait aucune
réforme et parvient à résoudre avant de
s'aligner sur place et je disais ça fait
une trentaine d'années que vous militez
avec votre association est ce que les
choses avancent en tout cas ce que vous
avez le sentiment qu'on vous écoute un
peu ce sens france dans le reste de
l'europe à ce qu'avait oui on nous
écoute un peu et il ya plusieurs
rapports donc nous en donnaient raison
des rapports jeudi par les interférences
et madame royal et monsieur mono le
sénat a proposé et connaît l'heure d'été
simple mais la com com actuellement le
royaume uni l'irlande
donc elles leur diffusion en hiver une
heure d'avancé en été et en europe
il ya eu un moment on avait dans des
situations des dialogues très
intéressante et ils ont voulu donc
réunir les pays
ça n'a pas bien marché par faute de
l'affluence et m'attendais et puis
maintenant voilà on attendait
impatiemment le résultat
une étude d'une direction générale la
mort et nous sommes les premières échos
que nous avons ne paraît pas pas très
bons ils disent ok tout peut pas
modifier la station actuelle parce que
voilà les pays se sont habitués à
travailler avec la même heure oui mais
avant aussi sans les changements d'heure
qui ajoute une
donc là on avait la même heure en hiver
du fait de l'avancement de la france
alors pourquoi je trouve qu'ils n'ont
pas beaucoup réfléchi et puis par contre
il ya une bonne nouvelle qui vient de la
russie où le changement d'heure avait
été supprimée par le monsieur medvedev
et déjà il ya quelques mois ils ont
annoncé qu'ils s'aligneraient toute
l'année sur leurs divers et il voulait
pas rester et toute l'année donc avec
une heure d'avancé puisque l'expérience
s'est montrée négatif il ya beaucoup de
succès les choses bougent un petit peu
même si ça va pas toujours dans le bon
sens au parquet de senlis êtes vous
toujours les finalités
il peut dire que vos arguments depuis
une trentaine d'années qui sont qui
peuvent être avancées l'aspect
technologique notamment on a des lampes
à économie d'énergie des choses comme ça
ça permet de faire des économies sans
avoir à changer
oui c'est aussi ce qui arrive aussi que
l'économie lien l'heure d'été qui est
une heure de moins de fonctionnement des
lampes et bien elle elle suppose moins
d'énergie vous savez la lampe des douze
va-t-elle vingt économistes et 12 20
heures alors que celle des 60 est connue
des lycées avant et que nous économiser
c'est une fois plus rien au regard ces
deux aspects concernant les lampes et
puis il ya eu plusieurs scientifiques
qui ont qui ont évalué vous savez sur 20
ans par exemple d augmentation des
accidents cardiaques
des incidents s'étaient ensuite des
accidents du travail donc aux etats-unis
et plusieurs équipes on mesurait d
orientation d accidents de la
circulation
ils les ont toujours mis en relation
avec la fatigue liée à l'heure d'été et
ça prouve alors on peut parler aussi
d'autres d'autres choses comme c'est par
exemple le retard apparent de la
sécrétion de leur mouvement
du sol du sommet qui est qui et les
études on voit quelle est la nuisance
que pour certains est limitée au moins
des sommets pour d'autres peut causer
des accidents des blessures et le même
l'amour merci à nos regards présidente
de l'association contre l'heure d'été
double et malgré tout pendant ce week
end il va falloir reculer d'une heure
nos montres merci aujourd'hui le journal
qui se poursuit et les vacances
également pour passer des moments en
famille la médiathèque et du canal de
montigny le bretonneux organise durant
cette période des pauses signer dès 16h
mercredi jeudi samedi enfants et parents
sont invités à l'auditorium pour des
projections gratuites de films familiaux
forcément c'est un événement qu'on fait
déjà depuis un certain temps et qu'on
essaye de systématiser pendant les
périodes de vacances scolaires
l'objectif c'est de toucher bien sûr les
enfants qu'ils soient ne partent pas en
vacances sorties qui s'ils sortent de
chez eux puisque quand ils viennent ici
avoir un événement heureux ça permet
donc aux enfants de pouvoir passer un
moment souvent avec leurs parents la
programmation elle doit rester à
l'intérieur sur des affiches parce que
c'est une histoire de droits d'image
même sans savoir le titre ils savent que
là il ya un moment pendant les vacances
scolaires notamment pour les enfants
c'est en cherchant sur internet que j'ai
vu des pauses au cinéma et je suis venu
par curiosité pour emmener ma fille
c'est une opportunité puis la ville et
l'agglomération est bien pourvu un
espace culturel pour les enfants les
adultes
donc ça permet de diversifier l'offre
vacances toujours et loisirs dans le
cadre de sa thématique sur la science la
maison de quartier
monod à guyancourt organisé cette
semaine un atelier gratuit d'initiation
à la robotique à l'occasion pour les 10
raisons de découvrir certains principes
mécanique
anthony rech a suivi l'atelier il dénude
et connecte les fils pour que dans
quelques heures il puisse être autonome
encadrés par un animateur cette douzaine
de jeunes fabriquent leurs robots sans
oublier la moindre étape du processus
mécanique franc limpide et quoiqu'ils
voilà signal intérieur qui va faire
démarrer le robot le moteur ensuite ça
va on va rajouter des roues et le coup
après sa tournée ça marche
et pour que l'ensemble des pièces
fonctionnent les enfants découvrent et
utilisent les outils traditionnels comme
lepisto cole ou encore là des nues 2 à
travers un atelier ludique ces jeunes
guyancourt toi apprennent par petites
touches les principes de la robotique
petit mécano surtout au niveau du
deuxième atelier pour la construction du
moteur on parle d' engrenage on parle
dax on parle de carter donc
effectivement on assemble tout ça on
visse ont créé un boulon au niveau des
engrenages ont leur on leur apprend
qu'elles sont la différence entre un
engrenage fixe et un engrenage mobile
qu'est ce que c'est que le principe du
couple pour un moteur voilà c'est un peu
ce genre de femme derrière cet atelier
d'initiation à la robotique
l'objectif de la maison de quartier de
démocratiser la science et qui sait une
fois ce premier robot terminer ce projet
fera peut-être naître certaines
vocations
voilà
nous passons à présent comme chaque
vendredi à l'essentiel de l'actualité de
la semaine et en politique mercredi on
retiendra la polémique lancée par le
nouveau député des yvelines benoît hamon
l'ancien ministre après s'être abstenue
sur le vote du budget a déclaré sur rfi
que la ligne suivie par l'exécutif
menacé la république c'est la
préparation d'un immense désastre
démocratique pour 2017 at il ajouté
celui qui a quitté le gouvernement fin
août a ensuite été repris par le
porte-parole stéphane le foll mais
benoît hamon prévient il ne quittera pas
le ps benoît hamon qui sera l'invité du
prochain 7,8 politique je recevrai à
l'ancien ministre fondeur mardi dès
18h30
politique toujours une visite dans les
quartiers pour la secrétaire d'état à la
ville afin de constater les réalisations
effectuées dans le cadre de la loi
d'orientation et de programmation pour
la rénovation urbaine c'est myriam el
khomri qui était jeudi après midi dont 4
apple a également rencontré les
habitants anthony rech et patrick
jacques de dixmude pour les images sont
ils ont essaimé pignard qui il y a
encore cinq ans les bâtiments de cette
pépinière d'entreprises n'existait pas
ils ont pu voir le jour grâce aux
programmes de l'agencé nationale de
rénovation urbaine l'anru avait alors
pour objectif de désenclaver les
quartiers dits sensibles
je pense qu'un trap a encore besoin du
soutien notamment de l' agence nationale
de renouvellement urbain en terme de
rénovation à gagner encore des choses à
finir à trappes
et puis là on lance une grosse dynamique
aussi autour des contrats deal et je
crois que ce qui est important c'est que
l'urbain soit au service de l'humain et
qu'il faut aussi favoriser une présence
massive des services publics sur cette
ville favoriser des actions favorisent
idée subventionné aussi les associations
pour qu'ils aient plus de lien social
pour recréer ce lien social au sein de
ces quartiers sensibles
en février dernier le gouvernement a mis
en place les contrats ville un
dispositif qui regroupe le
renouvellement urbain le développement
économique et la cohésion sociale si
dans quelques mois la commune de trappes
aura terminé le processus de rénovation
urbaine prévue dans le contrat signé en
2006 il reste encore trois chantiers la
cité nouvelle et les squares camus et
védrine
avec ce nouveau contrat ville la commune
saint-quentinoise souhaite axer ses
projets pour le futur sur l'éducation et
l'intégration républicaine tout ce qui
est compréhension de notre société
tu parles de la maison des parents je
parle des centres socioculturels tout ce
qui est participation à la vie publique
ça passe par des choses aussi aussi
simple apparemment mais aussi compliqué
dans la réalité de de comprendre le
français dans le cadre des contrats
ville le gouvernement prévoit de
débloquer 400 millions d'euros pour
redynamiser l'emploi promo paul en
cessation de paiement la pépinière
d'entreprises en très grande difficulté
dans la soirée de lundi une réunion
d'information a eu lieu dans les locaux
de montigny le bretonneux othman nation
le nouveau président a invité les
entreprises locataires pour éclaircir la
situation florane parfait 4 nuls à taux
elodie moines pour ce sujet les visages
sont soucieux plus ou moins inquiet ils
sont nombreux à s'être déplacés pour en
savoir plus sur le sort de promo paul
évidemment pour les vo lun gens mais il
n'a pas pu en voir vous n'ayez je vais
doublement la société ne fait plus face
à ses échéances depuis le mois de
février dernier avec 2,2 millions
d'euros de dette
la situation est plus que compliquée une
procédure collective est engagée la
pépinière va être placée sous la
protection du tribunal de commerce et un
administrateur va être nommé président
depuis juin 2014 othman nasro a évoqué
la possibilité d'un redressement
judiciaire pas de dépôt de bilan selon
lui la justice devrait se saisir du
dossier au mois de novembre
jusque là rien ne devrait changer pour
les entrepreneurs de promo pole dance
qui concerne de notre avenir et la
situation actuelle va effectivement
moi je n'ai pas vu venir je les ai
quasiment appris il ya quelques jours
moi je suis ici depuis 1992 donc on a vu
malheureusement une dégradation depuis 5
6 ans et sans aucune intervention
extérieure finalement merci d'avoir
organisé cette réunion à bagram en
pleine de franchise donc maintenant on
va attendre la prochaine échéance qui
minaude j'y crois pas beaucoup eu égard
à ce qui vient d'être dit je ne vois pas
comment les choses
mais quelle solution finale mauvaise
gestion selon othman nassr où une grande
partie du problème et dieu au site de
trappes en 2008 promo paul est nommé
titulaire de la délégation du service
public pour construire le site des
murisier aujourd'hui le déficit est de
1,8 million d'euros
à partir du moment où je découvre un
certain nombre de décisions qui me
semble surprenante ou en tout cas pas
favorable à l'intérêt de la société donc
je peux pas vous les détails et puis ce
qui effectivement ça sera à la justice
de dire ce qu'il en est réellement je
pense que l'argent public quand il était
investi doit aller réellement au profit
du plus grand nombre et j'ai le
sentiment que sur un certain nombre de
décisions qui ont été prises à propos
paul ça n'a pas été le cas
des paroles qui ont fait réagir guy
malandain maire de trappes
à cette période le président de propofol
était jean yves gendron est lui parti
communiste attrape aujourd'hui délégué
au développement économique de la ville
il ya un déficit important de la société
promo paul 40% de ce déficit vient de la
dsp mais c'est l'engagement c'était
l'engagement de promo paul quand ils ont
répondu à un appel d'offres il n'était
pas obligé de répondre et les autres qui
ont répondu avait aussi avait aussi
pendant plusieurs années toutes les ds
pc comme ça pendant plusieurs années
l'amortissement de la construction du
bâtiment qui joue sur qui joue sur les
comptes doit donc
donc là on est conforme à l'engagement
qui a été pris et signé par toutes les
parties pour le nouveau président quel
masque on parle des erreurs importantes
de gestion des fautes graves entraînant
un risque de conflit d'intérêt m aucun
local gambiaka aucun commentaire sur ce
genre de déclarations les sites merisier
thérèse seront repris par la ville de
trappes la situation de promo paul
devrait évoluer rapidement un premier
avis du tribunal de commerce sera donné
le 15 novembre
toujours dans l'actualité locale cette
semaine le secours populaire des
yvelines qui ferme son antenne des
clayes-sous-bois pour raisons sanitaires
un départ vingt ans après les premières
distributions alimentaires clark en
biais et william bell à la fin du mois
cette antenne du secours populaire
français fermera ses portes aux
clayes-sous-bois l'association était
présente depuis une vingtaine d'années
la mairie leur avait cédé ce local pour
faciliter les distributions alimentaires
et de première nécessité aux clés siens
dans le besoin mais ce local partagé
avec un autre organisme est aujourd'hui
trop vétuste et ne répond plus aux
normes d'hygiène et de sécurité
ils ferment 31 octobre et pendant une
semaine en fait pour faciliter
le déstockage on invite les habitants
des claies qui bénéficiaient de l'aide
du secours populaire à venir tout au
long de la semaine pour avoir un petit
peu plus d'aidé alimentaire parce qu'il
y avait d'habitude pour que les stocks
soient au plus bas pour ce qu'il va
falloir rendre les locaux du 24 octobre
au 1er novembre les bénévoles
distribueront également des vêtements
affaires scolaires ou encore vaisselle
la mairie n'a pas trouvé de solution
alternative à proposer
de son côté le secours populaire n'a pas
les fonds pour financer un local par ses
propres moyens
un coup dur pour les quelques 70
familles soutenues par l'antenne la
caisse primaire d'assurance maladie qui
veut rassurer autour du vaccin contre la
grippe chaque année une campagne lancée
à destination des populations les plus
fragiles pour permettre la gratuité de
la vaccination mais il est de plus en
plus difficile d'attirer le public on
écoute le directeur adjoint de la cpam
des yvelines invité du journal cette
semaine
depuis 2009 on assiste à une érosion des
résultats nous nous sommes partis de
plus de 60% de taux de vaccination en
2009 à fin 2008 et la dernière nous
étions à peine à 50 % sur l'ensemble de
la population contre à une perte de plus
de 10 points en cinq ans c'était plutôt
à kazan trippant pourquoi si vous parlez
d'un enjeu de santé publique
on peut s'étonner de ces résultats chez
préoccupant parce que je pense que
d'abord la population concernée est de
plus en plus importante le nombre de
personnes de plus de 65 ans augmente
je pense que parmi cette population
bon nombre d'entre elles considèrent
qu'ils ne sont pas concernés
et puis il faut aussi y voir les le
résultat des différentes campagnes de
vaccination qui ont été considérées
comme on va dire malheureuse ou non
appropriée par beaucoup de nos
concitoyens
c'est à dire vous pensez la grippe h1n1
a alléché a laissé des traces
l'association de prévention routière
abandonne les images chocs d'accidents
violents et
les mises en scène maintenons sont
plutôt portée vers la tendresse un
revirement de stratégie initiée à
l'occasion de ces vacances de la
toussaint vous allez dans un instant
entendre elles les réactions du
président de l'association 40 millions
d'automobilistes il était invité de ce
plateau marty je trouve que celle
campagne est intéressante et
intelligente parce que finalement nous
vivons tellement dans les images de
violence que pour une fois sans le monde
arrive à des images plus douce sur la
que j'avais de remarquer ça veut dire
que les images violentes les images
réelles d'accident ça ne fonctionne pas
forcément il faut les automobilistes si
vous regardez les médias vous regardez
la td récent arrêt des images de
violence on est tellement habitué à la
violence y compris sur les accidents que
à la limite personne ne fait plus
attention si on a des images douces voix
rim humoristique peut-être que la
tension le sera là et je crois qu'on est
tous pour pour la sensibilisation
puisqu'on est arrivé à un niveau tel de
répression qu'il faut faire autre chose
et la sensibilisation la prévention
l'éducation c'est quelque chose
d'extrêmement important et ça ça va
participer et voici donc ce spot réalisé
pour la prévention routière est lancée
pendant ses vacances
on est tous une bonne raison de rester
vivant association prévention routière
et vous quel est votre bonne raison
disponible en librairie depuis quelques
jours le livre noir du nucléaire
militaire son auteur jacques villain et
yvelinois historiens ingénieur il a
poursuivi sa carrière au ministère de la
défense et dans l'industrie spatiale et
il entend maintenant à rappeler à chacun
une histoire parfois oubliées au profit
des catastrophes de tchernobyl et de
fukushima
et ce même si la course à l'armement
nucléaire est à l'origine de nombreux
morts nous en avons parlé avec lui cette
semaine en plateau c'est une histoire
d'hommes
et puis on est quand même dans un
domaine qui n'est pas farcissent
facilement lisible par celui qui des
pâquis n'est pas au courant donc il
fallait à tout prix
je dirais adopté un langage qui soit
compréhensible par tout le monde donc
c'est pas recommencer mais il y a quand
même sous les gg pas pris la plume du
technicien
j'ai pris la plaine du technicien qui
s'adresse aux lecteurs qui n'est pas
averti
c'est clair que les grandes puissances
aujourd'hui ne sont plus dans
l'utilisation d'armes nucléaires sur le
champ de bataille
ils sont dans la dissuasion c'est à dire
faire peur pour éviter d'être envahi est
ce que c'est la même optique venant de
la corée du nord
est ce que c'est la même optique venant
du pakistan demain de l'iran
je n'en suis pas tout à fait sûr donc
c'est là où là le danger pour le 21e
siècle se pose c'est bien de
l'utilisation par ces nouveaux arrivants
de l'arme atomique dissuasion ou au
contraire utilisation l'intégralité de
cet entretien et d autres à revoir sur
notre site internet c'est la fin de
cette édition pour vos loisirs vous avez
rendez-vous sûreté défilent avec théo
lenne thorez pour une nouvelle édition
du 7 8 week end et ce vendredi soir
18h30 19h30 et 23 heures je vous
retrouve lundi pour le journal
vous